i mean ultimately it seems
that if you're introspective about life
it all it leads to a kind of acceptance
a deeper and deeper acceptance of the
whole of it
there again i want to be cautious about
acceptance because it almost says that
you can't
change it ah yeah it's it's sort of
embracing the struggle
and embracing the journey is the way
that i would put it so you ultimately
feel the
journey isn't just something that
happens to you your horse
you shape it you shape it remember how i
was saying that boston is the best
place and the best time to live in right
now you know in the history of humanity
i'm exaggerating a little bit but the
way that i think about this is
that if you look at the the whole of
cosmos
where would you rather be if you're just
a bunch of molecules roughly your
you know biomass where would you rather
be would you rather be a rock on mars
probably not would you rather be in a
black hole probably not
would you rather be an exploding
supernova maybe that might be
interesting
but being on earth is an awesome solar
system
an awesome planetary system an awesome
you know place to be in
across all of space-time it's a pretty
good place to be in as a bunch of
molecules
if you are a bunch of molecules on earth
today being an
animal with you know some kind of
awareness of the stuff around you is
wonderful being a human among all
animals
is amazing because you have all this
introspection
and being a human who's young fit
athletic
smart etc i mean you know you have so
much to be
happy for beyond that being surrounded
by a bunch of awesome people that you
interact with all the time
i mean i feel blessed to interact with
the people i know the friends i have the
dinners that i have
all of this the students that i interact
with i'm so blessed
and the last little little blip in this
awesomeness of local maximum
the last little blip comes from being
kind
being grateful and being kind i don't
know if you remember that little prayer
that i described last time
of thank you for all the good you've
given me
and give me strength to give unto others
with the same love that you've given to
me and
and the whole point of that is being
grateful and being kind
what does that do from a purely egoistic
perspective it makes the people around
you happier
and it takes that little maximum a
little bit further
because you'll be surrounded by happy
people by being kind
that's the purely egoistic view and the
purely altruistic view
or maybe it's egoistic as well is that
it just it's good to give
it feels good to give like basically
watching somebody who's touched by what
you said
watching somebody who's like
appreciating a rapid response or a
generous offer or just
random acts of kindness is so fulfilling
so evolutionarily we were selected for
that
there's just such a good feeling that
comes from that
you know it's fascinating to think you
said boston is the best place
and talking about kindness that the very
thought
that boston is the place best place in
the universe
is almost it's a kind of a gravitational
field
uh like your thought
and your very life in itself is a kind
of field that makes that real
yeah so the self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah and
by by claiming it's the best and
thinking is the best it becomes the best
and you make others
it's it's a for it's not a force that
just applies to your own
cognition exactly it applies to the
others around you
and then suddenly you live in even
better places yeah and because you it
creates the reality the
actual reality that the the social
reality
then it molds the environment exactly
what's one of the coolest things about
you i think
is uh you represent
uh the best of mit like the spirit of
mit
there's um so i'm i'm so glad
that i'm fortunate enough to be able to
talk to you because
um you know there's a kind of
cynicism about academia in parts
that i think is undeserved in that that
there's a
you know mit of course but academic
institutions
is a sacred place where ideas can
flourish
and just in the same very way that
you're talking about
is both kindness and uh
curiosity and that like that weird thing
that happens when a bunch of curious
descendants of apes get together and
just like get excited and this
this uh uh ripple effect that happens i
mean that's
the most beautiful aspect of mit people
might think like
competition and grants and
like uh position like you said the rat
race but like underneath it all
is is these curious human beings
inspiring younger human beings
and there's this uh ripple effect that
happens and i'm so glad
that i mean i'm glad that you
did i get a chance to record this
because it inspires so many other
students
and so many other people uh to do the
same to embrace
the inner curious creature that's not
about the race
so let's talk about the negatives let's
talk about no no no i'm serious i'm
serious wait you know
you have to embrace the good and the bad
so let's talk about the negative as
degree comes up
let's address it um so why do people
want positions of power
why do people want you know more money
more power more this more that
remember the part where i was saying if
you know who you are what other people
think about you
it makes no difference to you it only
teaches you about them
many people feel
um define themselves they feel
instantiated through the eyes of others
so being in a position of power
makes them feel better about themselves
who knows what other kind of struggles
they might have
that creates that need to feel better
about themselves
but they have a bunch of struggles and
everybody has a bunch of struggles and
every time i see somebody behaving
poorly i'm basically
thinking well they're in a tough spot
right now
and and it's okay you know i can i can
kind of see how i would behave badly
in other circumstances as well so i
think
if you take away that sort of having to
prove yourself
in the eyes of others life becomes so
much easier
so when i first became a professor at
mit
i started wearing adult clothes i had my
like
you know i mean before you became a
serious person
i i basically had you know i would i
would always like go around in my
rollerblades and my shorts and a t-shirt
and eventually i was a professional like
oh
i bought all these khaki pants and you
know these nice
like you know shirts with like you know
what they call it the
patterns and i was like you know
dressing with my nice belt every day
showing up
and then a few months later i was like i
can't stand it
and i just went back to my rollerblades
and my t-shirts and my shirts and it was
this struggle of sort of
not feeling that i fit in i was so
intimidated by all of my colleagues
like just watching their incredible
achievements like persons next to me and
the person
you know on the floor below me i was
like oh my god like
they clearly made a mistake what the
heck am i doing here how will i ever
live up to these people's standards
and um eventually
you grow up to realize that um the way
that i i grew up to realize that the way
that other people perceived my work
was very similar to the way that i
perceived other people's work as
flawless
i knew all of the flaws in my work i
knew
the limitations i knew what i hadn't
managed to achieve
and what i saw was maybe a third of the
way of what i was trying to achieve
and i saw everything as flawed what they
saw was what i had achieved
they didn't see what i hadn't achieved
they only saw the one-third down which
was pretty good in their eyes
so they all respected me and i was
feeling miserable about myself i was
like
i'm not worthy and i think that
this is a cognitive problem that we have
we kind of
um it's kind of like when we're talking
about artificial general intelligence
ati
of sort of we kind of have this
definition that anything that machines
can do
is not intelligent and anything that
they can't do is intelligent therefore
we narrow in our narrow narrow the field
of what intelligence truly means and as
soon as machines achieve something it's
not intelligent anymore
i feel like i was doing the same thing
with myself as soon as i could solve
something
it was the kind of thing that a kid like
me could solve and therefore it was kind
of easy
but to the others it seemed hard yeah
but to me it seemed easy so it was this
kind of thing that everything that my
colleagues were doing
seemed impossible to me but everything
that i was doing seemed impossible to
them
so it was that realization that sort of
made me mature into sort of a
not more confident but more comfortable
human being
you